it's the first of the month you know
what that means rents due
what's up guys I'm tired Matthew also
known as the landlord they called me the
landlord cuz I own the field and I take
care of chief Kingman right now my
social responsibility goes much beyond
that a lot of people have been impacted
by Cobra at 19 especially in my hometown
of New Orleans I'm hoping to find a few
families that I could really impact and
help and love and support I'm looking
forward to checking them out my name is
avery Matthews and I'm the program
coordinator at the IARC Center one of
our young artists
she's Shawn rain and his family are an
amazing part of our community
Keshawn has been diagnosed with autism
in 2017 and he has since served as a
voice for kids with autism his family
has taken on the role as advocates for
youth with autism his family volunteers
by everything this is an amazing family
and any help you could offer them would
definitely mean the walls for them thank
you so much tire shine I heard a lot of
good things about you oh really
man I heard deacons draw our good family
people I heard you spirited
kind of like by other people so I tried
I try to do the same thing okay I could
imagine y'all you guys have been through
a lot you know
grandmother thank you
a few days later we lost an eye and we
also I guess maybe a few days after that
we lost another actor within the matter
of a week we lost that you bet you bet
you are
I've had to deal with this I'm truly am
I know I can't be with the family with
you but you guys are not alone
I just want to actually guys how's
everything going financially like how
you guys how you guys holding up it was
it was pretty difficult you know it was
pretty difficult my husband works two
jobs so you know things were kind of
rough for a moment but thankfully he's
gone back to work and we're kind of
seeing a bit of normalcy now where you
guys can really continue to lean on each
other and push each other and each other
because you know you guys are family and
a lot of times that's all we have but
you've got my nickname at the landlord
right look
[Applause]
my cousins actually played little me
football with your brother Charlie no
New Orleans is a small place
[Music]